good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
and I believe in your potential and I
want to see that come out to help you go
off and find that amazing thing inside
you unleash it out into the world I
started to believe life series to try to
tackle some more personal issues
personal development topics that
hopefully if you can apply it to your
life you will be unstoppable
so today we're gonna look at how to
overcome your nerves and as always guys
as you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it in comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
as well enjoy
[Music]
I was watching the Olympics this last
Summer Olympics and I was amazed at how
bad the questions were that the
reporters would ask all the athletes and
almost always they asked the same
question whether they were about to
compete or after they competed were you
nervous right and to a tee all the
athletes went no right and what I
realized is it's not that they're not
nervous it's their interpretation of
what's happening in their bodies I mean
what it what happens when you're nervous
right your heart rate starts to go
you're you know you sort of get a little
tense you get a little sweaty right you
have expectation of what's coming and we
interpreted that is I'm nervous
now what's the interpretation of excited
your heart rate starts to go you become
you're anticipating what's coming right
you get a little sort of like tense it's
all the same thing it's the same stimuli
except these athletes these these
Olympic quality athletes have learned to
interpret the stimuli that the rest of
us would say is nervous as excited they
also the same thing no I'm not nervous
I'm excited and so I've actually
practiced it just to tell myself when I
start to get nervous that this is
excitement you know and so where when
you used to feet speak in front of a
large audience and somebody'd say how do
you feel you say a little nervous now
when somebody says how do you feel I'm
like really excited actually and it it
came from just sort of telling myself no
no this is excitement and it becomes a
little bit automatic later on but it's
kind of a remarkable thing to deal with
pressure by interpreting what your body
is experiencing as excitement rather
than nerves and it's really kind of
effective it makes you want to rush for
is rather than pull back and yet it's
the same experience all right I'm about
to go on stage they're seven that was a
people out there and it's so exciting
because what they don't know is they're
about to learn the five-second rule
we'll never be the same again now I got
to tell you my heart is racing
my armpits are sweating I have the exact
same physiological feeling as when I'm
afraid but I'm not afraid I'm excited
excitement and fear is the exact same
thing in your body it's just what your
brain calls it here's a trick that's
proven by science that I use every time
I speak when I start to sweat when I
start to have butterflies when I start
to have my heart race I say I'm excited
and I'm excited to get out there
I'm excited to talk to these people I'm
excited to share the five-second rule
and what that does is it sends a message
to my brain that tells my brain why my
body's all agitated and excited and that
way I don't feel afraid
remember excitement and fear exact same
thing in your body the only difference
is what your brain calls it I don't
negotiate with my mind
this I run this in my heart and soul I
don't let the brain when I use my brain
and let my brain use me everybody has a
place where they get fearful it's just
the human mind it's there it's not that
you're not gonna be fearful I think what
it really is is just again training
yourself to say I can be fearful and I
can do it anyway I don't have to get rid
of the fear I just have to dance with I
have to use the energy of it to move
myself forward and I found in the early
days I used to like I was trying to make
a decision I would do what I called my
rocking chair test I took a helicopter
ride one time we're flying straight
across all the people bumper-to-bumper
no stop this is the way to live what
would it take to learn how to fly a
helicopter money time energy where I'm
going to fit all this in what would life
be like I'm 85 years old I'm in my
rocking chair and
I flew helicopters and I took my friends
and family took the doors off leave
scream down on the water and we lived
this life where you can go wherever you
want the way you want I was like wow I
looked at what that life would be felt
it felt incredible and what if you never
learned what if you come up with all
these fears I don't have time another
money I don't know if I can do it I'm
gonna master it and we let the fears
dominate me and I never learn to fly a
helicopter I'm 85 in my rocking chair
and I look back on my life and I missed
out on all that but the fastest way to
deal with fear is do it anyway you don't
have to feel good to do stuff that's the
illusion make yourself do it what I've
trained my brain is what I say do it we
do it doesn't matter if it feels good
doesn't matter if it's too cold doesn't
matter if I don't feel it doesn't matter
if I'm fearful I do it anyway and when
you train yourself to do it anyway you
have a freedom most people never have
when you walk into an office you don't
go alone bring your people with you
bring everybody who has loved you with
you say grandma come on let's go
great grandpa you've been dead all this
time - Melissa I have to go in here and
have an interview come on auntie come on
my friends come let's go and when you
walk in people don't know what it is
about you they can't take their eyes off
you you may not be cute in the given
sense you may not be fashion models size
in that particular sense you may not be
any of those things but they can't take
their eyes off you and they say of you
in this incredible wave which I don't
understand they say I don't know but she
has charisma you know what you have is
all those people around you
so think of that anytime you have
anything to do bring everybody with you
that you can remember who has loved you
and then you have that sense of having
been paid for and when you walk in
people will say now I think you're
overqualified
there's an african-americans on 19th
century which is so great
it says when it looked like the Sun one
not shine anymore
God put a rainbow in the clouds imagine
and I've had so many rainbows in my
cards I had a lot of clouds but I have
had so many rainbows and one of the
things I do when I step up on a stage
when I stand up to translate when I go
to teach my classes when I go to direct
a movie I bring everyone who has ever
been kind to me with me black white
asian spanish-speaking Native American
gay straight everybody has to come with
me I'm doing a mistake come with me I
need you now long did you see so I don't
ever feel I have no help I've had
rainbows in my clouds if you've got to
do something that really makes you
nervous or that you're afraid to do
before you're about to do it come up
with an anchor thought what's an anchor
thought well an anchor thought is
something that's going to anchor you so
that you don't escalate any situation
into a full-blown panic attack or into a
situation where you screw things up it's
a way for you to anchor yourself so you
maintain control over what you're
thinking and how you behave so here's an
example with flying it's important when
you're creating an anchor thought to
pick something that is in the proper
context of what you're afraid to do so
for flying pick an anchor thought that
has to do with the trip that you're
taking so if I'm boarding a plane too
fly back home to Michigan an anchor
thought might be a picture in my mind of
my mom and I walking on the shores of
Lake Michigan where I grew up that's a
thought that makes me happy it makes me
excited and it's also related to the
trip that I'm taking if you have a
conversation that you need to have with
your boss pick an anchor thought about
how you feel after having that
conversation maybe it's you picking up
the phone and calling somebody that you
you love and saying oh my gosh it went
so well or you know you walking out of
the meeting and feeling like yeah I
survived that conversation I feel pretty
good about myself so now that you have
your anchor thought you're ready to beat
the fear how you're gonna do it is this
so let's go back to the example of the
plane I'm on the plane applying to
Michigan we hit turbulence my body's
gonna start getting agitated right I'm
starting to get nervous my heart starts
to race one of two things can happen I
can't control how my body might feel but
I can always always control what I'm
thinking about and I can always control
how I act and so can you
so when I'm on a plane and the
turbulence hits 5 4 3 2 1 that's step
one and it's essential and the reason
why using the five-second rule 5 4 3 2 1
is essential is because that is how you
switch the gears in your mind you awaken
your prefrontal cortex and you trigger
your brain that you're now in control of
your thoughts you've interrupted the
fear you've settled your thoughts and
now your brain is ready for that anchor
thought so then what I do after I go 5 4
3 2 1 is I insert the anchor thought
that I've already come up with before
the flight I start thinking about
walking on the beach and being with my
mom and my dad and I start telling
myself I'm so excited to walk on the
shores of Lake Michigan I'm so excited
to see my parents
now something remarkable is going to
happen in your brain because you've
interrupted the fear and because you've
used the five-second rule to assert
control and awaken your prefrontal
cortex and because you have an image
that can textually make sense to your
brain because your
flying to Michigan you know your brain
does your brain goes huh Mel's excited
to go to Michigan because my body is in
a state remember the first fact fear and
excitement exact same thing what's the
difference between fear and excitement
what your brain is saying using the
five-second rule in an anchor thought
you can actually switch the gears in
your mind and reframe the thoughts of
fear into thoughts of excitement and
because you have a vision that makes
sense based on what you're doing your
brain buys it you just tricked your
brain and Tom Hanks said something to me
when we were doing Saving Private Ryan
that always stuck with me which was I
was asking him about the move a movie
did with Jackie Gleason and I said what
was it like to work with Jackie Gleason
and he thought about it for a second he
said you know I made a decision to not
be nervous and I went what he goes I
just I knew everyone was so nervous
around him and I just said you know what
I'm not going to be nervous around him
I'm just and he and once he realized I
was treating him like you know a fellow
human being we really had this great
working relationship and it was really
good advice you know and so you try to
do that yourself I was trying to do it
with Tom Hanks at the time you know and
and yeah and yeah it's you don't get
anywhere being you know genuflecting my
name is Alex Parrish protecting our
country had always been my dream
Quantico was my first audition I knew I
had to go in to this room and read these
lines in front of all these people but I
was so nervous before I went in so I
went to the bathroom I remember before I
went in I looked in the mirror and it's
so stupid and please
but I talk to myself and I said what's
wrong with you you've played the most
difficult characters in in in the most
complicated movies I tossed my hair a
little bit felt great and walked huh
did my bit and got the job I think that
when I was younger I was you know you
get so like antsy and you just want the
good things to come and it's hard to
enjoy the process and I think that's
something that I really understand and
appreciate now I mean my life is so
chaotic with just being busy all the
time that I literally just take
everything one step at a time like even
when I'm on the stage and I'm like I
can't think about third act I'm in
second act now and I'm going to think
about the piqué arabesque I'm about to
do not about the you know the the
pirouettes I'm gonna do in two seconds
so it's literally just like taking
everything you know just pacing yourself
and one thing at a time I think that if
we woke up every morning and we looked
at our day or our careers as though
something was going to go wrong or
something could happen we couldn't reach
our fullest potential you kind of have
to just dive into every day like this is
the last time I'm going to do this I
think that's how you become the best
that's how you become your best self and
you know I don't step on to the stage
thinking I might fall tonight it's like
I'm gonna go for it and if I fall how am
I going to recover then you know that's
kind of the approach that you have to
have especially when you're at this
level that you can't think about you
know what if what if ya goes wrong and
just keep striving leading up to this
film well I guess the first time would
have been john c reilly Marissa Tomei
and Cyrus where I was really intimidated
to work with with actors that you know
we're so profound and and in Catherine
Keener and you know but each time you do
it you the first few rehearsals are the
first few scenes you're incredibly
nervous and then there's a point where
it kicks in where you're like I have
this job and if I want to keep this job
I better put all that stuff away info
I'm just doing what I came here to do
and giving the performance I came here
to give so same with Moneyball when we
were rehearsing when I first started
rehearsing Bennett and Brad Pitt and
folks Seymour Hoffman there was the four
of us in a room I was incredibly
intimidated and eventually you have to
be like they're going to hire somebody
else and fire me and I just knocked all
nervous and don't start acting well you
know so there just has to be that thing
you like I said if something bad happens
in your life you have to push it to kick
that stuff to the curb while you're
there doing your job and I think squirts
Martin Scorsese was a different thing
all together because yeah we did a month
of rehearsals and it would be me and him
and Leonardo DiCaprio in her room
rehearsing and I be like what the am I
doing here and I think I constantly in
my life whether it's Moneyball or even
you know you know the first movie said I
was ever on or whatever it is it's a
constant thing of what am I doing here
and I think that's the best attitude to
have is to always feel like you're the
person who doesn't belong because it
will drive you to do the best you can
not like I belong here but I want I want
to make sure that I do the work that
allows me to be with this great do you
still get nervous before you play a show
I'm nervous right now
yes thank you I'm you know I
my theory is is if you're not nervous
then something's wrong because there's
some intense stuff about to happen and
yeah there's a little there's a there's
always the jitters before you go out and
we have our little we have our little
huddle and kind of calm each other down
and you know say hey whatever happens is
supposed to happen so you know we try
not to take ourselves too seriously but
yeah we're nervous cuz it's a it's a big
deal and it's a you know it's important
you ever get frightened before a fight
you're getting nervous before a nervous
but not frightened I've been I'm nervous
because I have a great insight on I just
don't see the audience as every camera I
see millions of people like the Fraser
fight was watched by ten
100 million people which is five times
the population of everybody in the
United States just a picture Rina with 1
million people I met you couldn't see
them all and just think about 100
million and 10 hundred million and all
those people and everything that makes
me nervous just the idea of me just been
on my humble fellows in Kentucky got
good lucky in sports and now here is the
house a fight was piked in a place like
Thailand to the government house and
Arabia and the government officials took
time off to watch the fight and just
about two men boxing attracting so many
people of all races and nationalities
and how ye understand they they stopped
closed all the factories and the people
they said televisions on every street
corner people came out watching the
fight on the streets and every bar in
America every every house even traffic
was still doing that fight in Madison
Square Garden 10,000 people couldn't get
in and just over one man and just
imagine all them people watching you
that makes me nervous until till I get
started and then no notice do know in my
old videos I had a lot more passions a
lot more yelling you know I'd be
screaming at the camera and in the more
recent ones that that hasn't been there
and I was trying to figure out how to
get back to it and what I realized was
in the past four weeks I've I've had a
camera person helping me the first two
weeks were these two people I tried out
the past two weeks have been Jason who's
an amazing guy who's behind the camera
right now and I found myself being a
little more nervous a little a little
safer a little more guarded I found that
I was talking faster on my videos than I
was in the old ones and my old process
used to be I would look at whatever I
was gonna talk about whatever question I
had and I would you know pace around my
my my place for a couple minutes think
of what I wanted to say then get right
in the camera and start saying it and I
didn't care if I was yelling or
screaming or you know whoever was in the
office and and now I find you know we've
got to set up the shots and and there's
somebody who's you know watch everything
I'm saying and as a result again I feel
a little guarded and I'm not as
passionate as I used to be and I feel
like it's because I'm a little bit
nervous and I think you know hopefully
you can relate to this whether you're
stretching your comfort zone and doing
new things to help your business grow
and you get a little bit nervous about
it and the easy thing for me to do would
be to say well this is scary this is new
this is boundary-pushing
so I'm gonna go back to his room before
because that's safe and that that worked
but that's not in the best interest of
my business that's not in the best
interest of this channel that's not of
the benches of you guys because the
production quality has gone way up and
we get videos done so much faster we can
have some fun with the b-roll and the
quality is way better than I was doing
it myself and the key is then for me to
get better to me to get more comfortable
for me to stretch my comfort zone and in
that stretch it is by definition
uncomfortable and a little bit scary and
it just requires breaking through your
nervousness and conquering your
nervousness it's okay to be nervous you
know when you're trying new stuff but
it's not being a slave to those nerves
and not holding back on what you want to
do because you're scared or nervous so
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of this video what are you
going to take from this and immediately
apply it somehow into your life or your
business I would love to hear your
thoughts please leave it down in the
comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to bull Hawkins from
four-minute masters both thank you so
much for picking up a cup of my book
your one word and for the exposure you
gave me on your channel I really
appreciate the support and I'm so glad
you enjoyed the read today I'm joined by
the outstanding Evan Carmichael so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love guys I'll see you soon
[Music]
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]